When it comes to being a Roman emperor, if you want to be remembered,
there seem to be two sure-fire ways of doing it.
One is to be a capable ruler and day strong military leader men like all Gustus
Trajan and Vespasian come to mind.
The other is to go completely mad with power like Caligula,
a narrow for better or worse history does seem to love a blood thirsty
deranged lunatic. Marcus Aurelius,
an emperor who we've already covered was firmly placed in the first camp.
Therefore,
it wasn't unusual to expect his son communists to follow in his footsteps,
but he did it. Nope. In fact,
commerce was about as far removed from his father's legacy.
As one would think possible.
Columbus was born on August the 31st 161,
a D in VM, the modern day city of LA Movio,
about 20 miles Southeast of Rome. He was the son of Roman emperor,
Marcus Aurelius, and his wife Faustina. The young guy,
comatose was born in the purple meaning that he was born during the reign of his
father. He was the 17th Roman emperor,
but the first to be born under these conditions,
as common as himself said in a speech, I never knew the touch of common cloth.
The pebble received me as soon as I came forth into the world and the sun shone
down upon me, man, and emperor. At the same moment, you might see things,
this set him up for great things,
but historian Cassius DEO described kilometers as being as guileless as any
man that ever lived characterizing him by cowardice ignorance and great
simplicity in 166,
the five-year-old competence was named Caesar by his father,
which by that point was a dynastic title meant to designate him as the out of
the throne.
Microsoft radius also appointed another one of his sons and he has verus as
Caesar showing this,
he intended for the two brothers to rule jointly as he did with his own sibling
Lucius versus however, any us verus died in 169 a D.
And for whatever reason,
his father decided against the pointing and other Caesar and kept comedies as a
sole lap in doing so.
He broke with the tradition established by the post five room and rulers or the
five good emperors as they were known where each one selected his successor
and adopted him. Instead,
Microsoft radios hopes that he could mold his own flesh and blood into becoming
a great ruler.
He provided commiters with the best education that money could buy,
paying large fees for scholars to come live in Rome and to tutor his son.
He took commiters alongside him during military campaigns,
even when he was young,
so that he may learn how to command an army and 177 Ady Marcus
Aurelius granted the title of all Gustus to comedies thus equaling his own
status and making his son ruler even.
So he realized that the new emperor were still impatient and immature.
In the last years of his life,
Marcus Aurelius appointed many of his most generals and companions to serve as
advisors to comedies Ben in 180 AED while engaged in the macro manic Wars,
he died leaving his son as the new sole emperor of Rome.
Commodus was 18 years old. When he took over the throne in the middle of a war,
he could have been a good ruler.
If he would have been inclined to listen to the many guardians that his father
had provided for him. Instead,
it did not take long for him to start ignoring them completely to pursue his own
whims or even worse. The ideas of his sycophantic entourage.
It was these people that Cassius DEO blames for the initial corruption of
calamitous. He called the young emperor,
the slave of his companions in Greek historian.
Herodians agreed that these courtiers took advantage of the naive ruler and
filled his head with tales of pleasures and delights awaiting. And back in Rome,
communists soon made up his mind. He wanted the water ends,
not because of the bloodshed or because it was best for Rome,
but because he wanted to return to his palace and start living the lavish life
of an emperor. At this point in the war,
Rome had the clever advantage by pressing on.
They could have neutralized enemies who had been causing problems for 15 years
against the advice of all of his generals.
Communists told them to negotiate peace as soon as possible.
And so the macrobiotic Wars ended in 180 with terms favorable to Rome,
of course,
but still mild compared to what they could have been back in the capital of the
empire does through a celebration in his honor, gold,
a triumph with games and music and feasts and handouts to the Roman populace to
win over the people. In fact,
comatose managed to retain his popularity with the common man throughout most of
his 12 years. So low rain,
mainly because he was often willing to open the raw coffers and spend money on
lavish spectacles, even.
So it did not take long before those around him started to plot against the
emperor in 182 Ady comma discerns, the IRA of his older sister, Lou cellar,
who was married to Claudius Palm.
Pena's one of the most distinguished generals on DeMarcus Orelia.
So now mostly served as an ignored advisor to the new emperor.
Before this Lucinda had also been married to Lucius verus Marcus Aurelius,
his brother and co Ambra,
Def all blue silver had been granted the title of all gusta and all the Imperial
honors that came with it. When communists became member,
though he married broody or spina,
and all of a sudden all of the privileges of being Rome's highest ranking woman
were afforded to her and Lucila considered this a great insult.
She knew there's a husband,
Paul Benitez would not take part in a plot to assassinate comedies.
So instead she turned to a young nobleman named Marcus or medius
quadratus, and the honest, who was also rumored to be her lover,
quadratus enlisted the help of a Senator named Quintin.
Deanna Sue agreed to attack the emperor in the entrance of an amphitheater under
the shroud of darkness. According to historian her audience,
[inaudible] had the opportunity to slay commerce,
but made the mistake of delivering a little speech beforehand,
telling him that the Senate wants to him debt.
The time he wasted was enough of the emperor,
his bodyguards to pounce on him and kill that would be assassin was the first
plot on commerce as life afterwards came an investigation and everyone suspected
of taking pots in the plot was put to death.
This included quadratus and even the emperor sister Lucila,
but curiously enough, Palm Pena's was sped.
Maybe commiters genuinely believed that the general played no part in the
matter,
or maybe he still felt some kind of deference for one of his father's closest
allies,
either way Claudia Pena's was allowed to quietly retire away from Romans,
go and live on an estate in the country, citing his old age as an excuse.
Cassius DEO gave an interesting accounts of a man named [inaudible],
who managed to fake his death and evade. The wrath of calamitous.
This family had been implicated in the assassination plot and his father and
uncle had already been executed. When he heard that he too had been condemned.
Jeff Colombianas took a hat, killed it and drank its blood to this,
kept him in his mouth. Instead of swallowing,
he then wrote his hauls and fell on purpose, vomiting up the blood.
Those around him thought that he had been gravely injured and took him to his
bed to believing that he was at death, his door,
nobody questioned when new spreads that he had died. But by that point,
he had already disappeared instructing his sevens.
Do you place a Ram's body in his coffin and Burnett comatose eventually learned
of the deception and scoured the embar, looking for the man,
but it was allegedly never found. And his ultimate fate remains a mystery.
[Inaudible].
On his life, had a major impact on comedies his behavior.
He took the words of Quinton's Yannis to heart.
And from then on considered the Senate,
his enemy throughout his whole rain calmness looked for new ways of curtailing
the power of senators and other wealthy officials,
including having the executed and their property confiscated after all the money
that he spends on his lavish lifestyle had to come from some wet.
Whenever a power vacuum is created someone new,
always steps up to try and fill that void. As the sentence is lost,
their authority and influence other people from calmness is in a circle Rose up
to improve their station. One of these was tikka Diaz, parentless.
So he was elevated to the position of Praetorian prefect.
At the beginning of calmness, his rain and steadily gains more power for a time.
He was even considered the de facto ruler of Rome.
He was more than happy to let the embroidering gauge in his licentious wins and
games. Well, Perez took on more administrative duties.
He also turns the emperor against anyone.
He perceived to be a threat to his authority by convincing comatose that they
were plotting against him.
This is how he got rid of the other Praetorian prefects.
[inaudible] implicated him in a plot to assassinate the emperor. Also,
according to her audien,
Puranas targeted the wealthiest senators sands by confiscating their properties
made himself the richest man of his time.
Understandably Purina's end himself a lot of enemies.
Some because of his actions and other zoo was simply envious of his privileged
position. But as it turns out,
he could not convince communists to have them all executed.
As there were other people apart from him who were in the emperor,
his good graces, one of them was Marcus Aurelius clans,
a Friedman born in [inaudible] region,
which is today part of Turkey clans who had also risen through the ranks by
being a part of [inaudible] is in a circle.
Cassius Dio said that he possessed the greatest influence after parentless,
which is perhaps more impressive as clans a had originally been brought to Rome
as a slave to serve as a pack carrier. However, by 182 80,
he was working in saline, the Imperial household,
after the assassination plot clans or killed Commodores,
his chamberlains say a terrorist who allegedly was part of the conspiracy and
deceived his position, thus entering into the, his close confidence
[inaudible] and both vying for the same position.
That's at the emperor's most trusted sidekick. They hated each other.
And we're always looking for ways to get rid of one another. In the end,
it was cleanser who triumphed if only for a little while and 185 AED,
a curious scene unfolded during the capital league games,
celebrating Jupiter as the crowd filled with this red comidas took his seat on
the Imperial chat on old man,
apparently dressed like a philosopher or ran out into the center of the stage.
He said to the emperor, the sword of parentless was at his throat.
He warms that the Praetorian prefecture was raising an army to oppose comatose
who was sure to face death.
If he did not deal with the threat immediately for his efforts,
the old man was seized on the orders of Paramus and burned to death.
Comatose did not know how to react.
It was true that Prentice had convinced the emperor to place one of his sons in
charge of the army at the Lyrica Roman province.
But his suspicions were not raised enough to act against his confidence.
Not yet at least, but another events go to short while later,
which persuaded communists that Perez had ambitions over, throwing him.
A group of soldiers arrived in Romans without parenthesis knowledge went
straight to the emperor. They had come from the prefect sun in Lyrica,
where they had discovered that he had begun minting coins with the prefects
portrait on it. And anticipation of parenthesis claiming the throne.
This was enough proof for commerce who had Paramus arrested and beheaded later,
having a son killed as well.
It is unclear whether or not this plot was actually real lens where the
apprentice was indeed planning a coup or if it was just a ruse to get rid of
him, perhaps engineered by his most bitter enemy Clevelander,
her Odean makes no claim or suggestion that parentless had been the victim of a
conspiracy,
but Cassius DEO portrays the prefects in a positive light saying that he lived a
most incorruptible and temperate life and he guarded commodities and the
Imperial office.
He also mentions that whenever something bad against Pernice a cut planter was
there to whisper in the emperors. Yeah.
And ultimately it was he who convinced communists to deal with the prefects
permanently after the death of horrendous,
who was the most powerful man in the empire after calmness, of course.
And he refrains from no form of mischief selling or privileges and
indulging in wantonness. And w
The next attempted plots against communists actually came soon after this one in
187, a D, but it was only mentioned by her audience.
So we aren't sure how accurate it is. It concerns a soldier named Materna.
So deserted his Legion and assembled them all without walls,
to pillage towns and villages throughout the empire.
It was a situation similar to that of Spartacus where maternity freed slaves and
is ever increasing army became strong enough to attack in Ponta cities.
Eventually the mall then digitally itself,
and the maternity set his sights on the grandest prize possible the throne of
Rome. However, despite his army growing to a size, he would never have expected.
Battalion has realized that it still wasn't capable of standing toe to toe
against the Praetorian guard. Therefore,
we reasoned that accounting assassination plot would be preferable to an all out
battle. Matanzas picked the perfect time for it. It was the beginning of spring,
and the Romans were celebrating a festival honoring the goddess side. Bella,
of course it was grand spectacle because if there was one thing,
comatose was good at, it was throwing a party during the revelry.
It was customary for people to dress up and on this occasion,
no official or religious uniform was off limits.
Anyone could dress up as anyone else.
So maternalism is met and domes the uniform of the Praetorian God hoping that it
would get them close to the emperor on paper. This sounded like a good plan,
but it ended in failure as Matanzas was portrayed by some of his men,
he was captured and executed while comidas escapes yet another attempt on his
life by this point, comatose couldn't help.
But notice that despite all his executions,
there were always new people appearing who wanted him debt.
He was never the most attentive emperor in the world,
but these plots persuaded him to spend less and less time in public.
It was out of Rome.
Most of the time preferring the remoteness and security of his private estates.
This left the empire in the charge of others,
mainly cleanser like Peronists before him fans used his position to make himself
the richest man in Rome, he's old governorships, military commands,
senators ships, and even appointed 25 consoles in a single year.
Something which had never been done before.
He was careful to send a launch part of his money to kilometers so that the
emperor would not feel slighted or ignored, but of course,
nothing lasts forever and Glenda to have to fall.
This happens in 198 D and the previous year Rehman had been hit first by a
plague that a feminine,
the people were angry and they blamed Leander as he became rather notorious for
his greed.
That was also the room at true or not that the official had hoarded large
supplies of grain because he thought this was the one way to control the masses,
this and the opposite effects though.
And riots broke out as violent mobs demanded his death plans, uh,
trying to put an end to this.
He sends out the Imperial cavalry to chase down the rod ism gave the order to
slaughter them all without mercy, but even this didn't work.
Cause people barricaded that houses climbed on their roofs and started pelting
the riders with rocks and other projectiles,
eventually word of the rod and the bloodshed reached commiters who lived
blissfully ignorance of the problems of the Romans plans and made sure of that
after all.
But this time there was nothing he could do save himself during the civil war
was ready to break out.
The emperor had clan to seized and beheaded and placed his head on a spear and
sent it into the cheering crowd. Afterwards gland, his sons were killed as well.
All of his closest associates and their bodies were again,
turned over to the ravenous mobs suit that they could desecrate and mutilate
them to the heart's content and satiate that blood loss as the situation quieted
down, Commodus realized that once again, he elevated peril,
he was angry once he understood just how much power can Andrew had managed to
attain. So he concluded that it was time for another series of executions and
assassinations of the prominent men of Rome who could pose a threat to him. Wow.
You noticed by this point that we haven't spent a lot of time talking about the
things has did as emperor.
That's mainly because despite a lengthly 12 year reign,
there isn't much to talk about, Oh,
well did breakouts in Dacia and revolt in Britain,
but these were both solved relatively quickly.
Plus it's not like communists played any part in them. It was his generals.
Like [inaudible] Claudius Albania's and pacinian Nijah your actives.
And all three of them would go on to have short range zipper in the near future.
For the majority of the rain colada stayed completely detached from his
administrative concerns.
He was too busy playing games and having feasts to bother himself with trivial
matters such as or running an empire.
It wasn't until the last few years after the death of [inaudible],
the communists became more involved.
And that is when he truly indulged his egomania and madness.
For starters, he decided that he was the reincarnation of Romulus,
the legendary founder of Rome.
Therefore this allowed him to found the city again and rename it. Comedy Ana,
indeed, the people were no longer Romans, but comma deans not satisfied.
Commenters also concluded that he was the reincarnation of Hercules and had
statues erected of him where he was depicted,
dressed like the mythological hero,
swinging a club and wearing the pelt of an Indian lion.
It took on a few other names and titles and as evidenced by the official
greeting to the Senate, the emperor Caesar, Lucius alias,
or really as communists or Gustus Pius, Felix somatic, as dramatic as Maximus,
Britannica, pacifier of the whole death, invincible, the Roman Hercules.
[inaudible] Ms. Holder of the tribute and authority for the 18th time in
parameter of the eighth time console of the seventh time father of his country
to consoles pages. Tribunes on the fortunate comedy and Senate reading. Yes.
All of the names that we just mentioned Coleman just use them to rename the
months of the year in his honor,
because he saw himself as Hercules coladas did something no other emperor had
done before.
He became a gladiator and actually taking parts and fights and sight the
emphasis. Well,
actually he was more of a Beastie Arius if we're being technical,
as he generally prefer to fight animals and our humans. And when we say fight,
we mean in an obviously rigged situation that pose no threat to him whatsoever.
When he went against animals,
comidas usually hunted them from an elevated platform where they couldn't reach
him. Only if the animals were harmless would come at us,
have actually entered the arena floor to give him his due.
It appears that [inaudible] was a skilled marksman and could easily bring down
animals from a fall with areas and javelins. If the emperor was fighting,
other people, they obviously knew not to harm him.
Not that they would have been able to, even if they wanted,
as they were armed with objects, such as ones and sponges,
and for each performance, communist paid himself.
1 million says disease somewhere around $2 million today,
which also made him the highest paid gladiator of all time.
Garcia who as a Senator of room during the time of commerce was front and center
for all of this, by the way,
mentions one episode where the emperor beheaded an ostrich,
he then approached the senators and pointed his bloody sore to them than the
ostrich head suggesting that would be them one day, according to DEO,
he and the other senators got in the habit of secretly chewing Laurel leaves
while attending these spectacles. So as not to burst out,
laughing in front of the emperor, all of them had to attend these events.
And all of them did except Claudia's Palm Pena's who says that he would have
preferred death overseeing the son of Marcus Aurelius in this business.
[Inaudible].
What does sort of escaped quite a few plots against him during his reign,
but it was inevitable that eventually his time would run out.
This happens on new year's Eve,
192 80 during the celebrations communists wanted to make an appearance,
not from the Imperial palace, as well as tradition,
but from the gladiatorial barracks wearing armor and surrounded by the other
gladiators,
he shared his plans with Marsia his favorite mistress who then started crying
and begging commiters not to disgrace himself in such a way.
He also told a collector so trusted servants and Amelia's laters the Praetorian
prefects because they reacted in a similar way. None of this changed his mind,
of course,
but the emperor did decide to have the three executed for their insulins and
secretly wrote down their names on the list of people to be killed at the start
of the new year. As it happens,
Marcio came into possession of this list and shadow findings with latest and to
collect us, they had this whole choice.
It was either them or kilometers and unsurprisingly. They chose the last app.
Later that day, as the embryo was taking a bath,
Masia brought him a cup of wine,
which had been poisoned Coleman has drank the whole thing,
but it caused him to be violently ill, vomiting, the lethal liquid,
before it had time to do its job. It was now far too late to back away.
So the conspirators bribed a young,
strong wrestler named narcissist to enter the bathroom and strangle the emperor.
And so he did, and this was not only the ends of commenters,
but also that's another ans nine dynasty.
His death was followed by one of the most turbulent periods in Roman history,
known as the year of the five embers.
But we can talk about that another day.
So I really hope you did enjoy this video. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Thank you for it.